recently i was lucky enough to have
robin wright on the show and
what she kept emphasizing when talking
about wonder woman was how patti just
really pushed to make her movie her way
and
at one point she specifically says that
she gets what she wants
without being mean about it which is it
sounds like such a simple but
it's so important and i don't understand
why everybody in the industry doesn't
adopt that approach to getting what they
want but anyway
is there any example you remember from
shooting that movie where you saw patty
use that skill set in order to make the
movie that she wanted to make
ah absolutely i mean she was very clear
about
like you know what the amazons were
supposed to be
you know and i think that that had
originally been like
some idea that the amazons had been
deeply traumatized by
some kind of like horrible event um
that involved rape mass rape and and
uh and patty just said
no no no we're not gonna put that on
those amazons uh we don't wanna start
out seeing them
as victims and why would we let's just
get rid of that part
and and make sure that these are
these are heroes in their own term
they're not like
uh you know they've not been you know
part of the victims of history you know
they're
they're these unbelievably
uh uh courageous women and we're not
gonna saddle them with the trauma
uh from the outset we're going to
uh have them uh be received by people
on the basis of who they are what is
their culture why are they so fierce
what does it mean to live on an island
where there are no guys
that made so much sense you know you
needed them
to have like a very uncomplicated
background in order to be able to just
accept them
as the heroes that they are and um
and that's part of her clarity
the reason why she does that is and gets
it gets what she needs to get is because
she's very clear
she's very clear thinking and she's able
to
transmit those ideas in a very clear
way um and so she doesn't need to be
mean
she doesn't need to push the envelope
because she's right
she's thought it through she knows what
she's talking about
she's super well prepared she has great
instincts
she's a great director and she's a great
visionary
in her own right she sounds like a great
leader on set too and that's another
reason why i admire her so so much
yes she is she is great and there is not
a time where she will not take the five
minutes to talk to even like
the most minor character on the set
she'll remember their names and she'll
be like respectful of them
and and she will give them that moment
on screen as well
that registers and is necessary to
really
bring together what is a community if
you only have three people in a
community and you don't know who all of
the other people are and you don't
recognize in them
a distinct personality you don't really
have a community and that's how she does
it like she creates
like this whole full-fledged experience
by having that razor eye for detail
you